welcome back everyone this is part three
in our series on in context learning
I've called this part the current moment
that is either foolish or foolhardy or
both the current moment is surely going
to change very fast as the field changes
I think I can say that the lessons here
will be useful no matter what direction
the field takes next
as always I want to start with data data
used for self-supervision this is an
incredibly important ingredient when it
comes to understanding the behaviors of
our large language models this is a
slide that I used in a previous
screencast but I augmented it with the
Colossal clean crawled Corpus C4 this is
a data set that was created as part of
the T5 modeling effort and it is audited
by Dodge at all 2021. and it's a sort of
interesting side note the Washington
Post did an article that is essentially
about the data set and the auditing work
that Dodge at all did they called that
article inside the secret list of
websites that make AI like chat GPT
sounds smart
I'm not sure secret is appropriate here
because it seems like everyone is being
pretty open about what is in C4 but
nonetheless the article is very useful
in terms of helping you People Like Us
audit what was in data sets like that
and undoubtedly
the data that are used for unsupervised
pre-training are an incredibly important
ingredient when it comes to
understanding what our models can do and
where they're Limited
but as I mentioned at the end of the
previous screencast this is no longer
the only ingredient we have left the era
when all of the language model
pre-training was simply unsupervised
language model pre-training we have now
entered into the era of instruct fine
tuning
unfortunately we know much less about
what is happening with instruct fine
tuning we don't really know what the
large industrial labs are doing in terms
of data and protocols here we can infer
that they are paying lots of people to
generate instruct data and that means
that very often these people are doing
quite sophisticated things for example I
think people might be prompted with a
text that says write a certain kind of
Python program and then a human actually
writes that Python program and that's
just one instance of many kinds of
domains and areas of expertise where
they have recruited people to exemplify
the desired Behavior again a reminder
that the really sophisticated things
that we're seeing from language model
these models these days are not emerging
in some magical way from unsupervised
pre-training but rather emerging very
directly from standard good
old-fashioned supervision
I think we can also infer that these
large industrial labs are using their
own models to generate examples and
adjudicate between examples and in fact
we're going to review a method along
those lines self-instruct in just a
second
if you would like to get a feel for what
instruct fine-tuning is like I would
encourage you to check out the Stanford
human preferences data set this is a new
release on instruct fine-tuning data set
that was derived from Reddit posts and
so you could use that maybe using
subparts of it or different protocols
for fine-tuning to get a feel for how
instruct data affects model behaviors
and that could be quite Illuminating
I mentioned self-instruct before I think
this is a powerful method that points to
lots of new ways in which we could use
models to make models better
for self-instruct We Begin from 175
tasks that were written by humans
those going to a task pool and then we
have a language model generate some new
instructions via in context learning
the generated instruction is then fed
back into that same language model with
a new kind of prompt that helps the
model decide whether the instruction is
a classification task or some other kind
of task
depending on the generated response at
step two we feed the generated output
into one of or another of these two
prompts down here and that step gives us
new input output pairs that we can use
for subsequent supervised language model
pre-training
there's some filtering there for quality
and to make sure the data set is diverse
but then those generated instructions go
back into the task pool and can
participate in parts of these prompts to
generate more data
and in that way we can use a language
model to bootstrap a new data set and
then we can update that very same
language model with the new data set in
the hopes that that will lead it to have
more and more diverse abilities
that was kind of abstract so let's walk
through how self-instruct happens at the
level of the prompts that they use so
it's step one we have instruction
generation this is the prompt you can
see the model is given eight
demonstrations and then asked to
generate a new instruction
the majority of these demonstrations
were human created but in subsequent
rounds of self-instruct some of them
were actually model generated
instructions
at step two we have classification task
identification the generated response
from Step One is fed into this prompt
and the model learns in context to
predict whether or not it was a
classification task depending on the
generated response there we either feed
it into a classification task prompt or
a non-classification task prompt and the
results here give us new input output
pairs that we can use to augment our
self-instruct data set and then as I
said we do subsequent language model
supervised pre-training in the standard
way or maybe with some other techniques
to update the model that was used for
this generation process
that self-instruct self-instruct was a
major mechanism behind alpaca alpaca was
an important recent moment for the field
because it started to show people that
we could via self-instruct methods take
relatively small models like a 7 billion
parameter model do some instruct fine
tuning and get a very capable result as
the output
in more detail the way alpaca works is
we begin with a llama model llama is a
class of models that were was released
recently by meta AI
the alpaca team began from the 175 tasks
that were written by humans for the
self-instruct paper and then they follow
self-instruct with some minor
simplifications using text DaVinci 3 as
the engine to create the new input
output pairs that gives them a data set
ultimately of 52 000 examples and those
examples were used to update the Llama
model to create alpaca and the
observation is that the results of this
relatively small scale effort to update
the Llama model are actually quite
powerful in terms of imbuing alpaca with
new instruct following behaviors
and again there's a major lesson there
about technology and I think this is an
exciting New Direction for the field as
we think about making these relatively
small models ever more performant and
there is also a lesson for you about
what's going to be effective for
in-context learning because obviously to
the extent that you can tune your own
prompts to align with the instruction
fine-tuning data that models like alpaca
have seen you will be more successful in
that lesson generalizes to all these
large language models
for some we have visibility into the
instruct fine-tuning data as with alpaca
but for the largest ones we don't and so
people have to kind of organically
discover which prompting techniques work
which is really a process of uncovering
I believe what their instruct fine
tuning phase was like at this point
alpaca as I said was exciting because it
kind of bucked the trend of model sizes
going up up up this is a slide that I
used in the intro lecture for the course
we got all the way up to Palm at 540
billion parameters it may be that gpt4
is substantially larger even than that
as a result of this kind of instruct
fine tuning we're starting to see that
model sizes might come down and
nonetheless be very in performant and
that is incredibly exciting because it's
going to happen there are lots of
incentives intellectual technological
Financial for us to find a way to have
smaller models be performant and I think
that will be an important step toward
actually truly democratizing access to
large language models and the
capabilities that they can enable